오늘 저는 한국어와의 투쟁에 대해 이야기하고 싶습니다.
저는 제가 어떻게 다른 언어를 배웠는지,
그 과정이 저에게 어떤 과정이었는지, 어디에서 성공했고
왜 그랬고 어디에서 어려움을 겪었는지
에 대해 조금 이야기하고 싶습니다 . 제가 어려움을 겪었던 일부 언어에는 한국어,
아랍어가 포함되며 그 이유에 대해 알아보겠습니다. 오늘은 한국어에 대해 이야기하겠습니다.
제가 한국어를 처음 접한 것은 1972년이었습니다.
오래 전 일입니다.
아내와 나는 일본에 살고 있었다.
우리는 그것을 보기 위해 한국에 방문했습니다.
나는 일본과 일종의 언어 관계가 있는
아시아 대륙에 있는 한 나라에 관심이 많았습니다.
기본 구조가 북아시아에서 유래했고, 교착어이며, 물론
한국어와 일본어 모두 중국어가 매우 지루했습니다.
그리고 물론 중국으로부터의 엄청난 문화적 차용도 있습니다.
그래서 관심이 많았습니다.
한국이 개발도상국으로 여겨졌을 때 멋진 방문을 하셨지만
지금 우리가 알고 있는 것처럼 정말 발전하고 있었습니다. 나는 1976년에 다시 갔다.
좋은 친구가 캐나다 대사관에 있었다.
그는 결혼하고 있었다.
그는 내가 그의 결혼식에서 최고의 남자가 되기를 원했습니다.
걔가 한국여자랑 결혼해서 내가 그랬어.
그 때 한국어 공부 책을 몇 권 샀는데
한국어 공부 책이 있는 도서관을 보여드릴게요
. 네, 하지만 별로 하지는 않았어요.
나는 일본으로 돌아갔고, 그곳에서 나는 당시에 살고 있었다.
그리고 1980년에 한국을 방문했습니다.
저는 캐나다 원자력 에너지에서 일하고 있었습니다.
캐나다가 한국에 원자로를 건설하고 있었기
때문에 한국과 매우 관련이 있을 것이라고 생각했습니다
. 하지만 결국 저는 캐나다의 Atomic Energy에서 1년을 보냈습니다.
그런 다음 산림 산업으로 돌아갔습니다.
다시 말하지만, 한국 공부에 대한 나의 초기 분출은 일종의 튜브 아래로 떨어졌지만
여전히 거기에 있었습니다.
그리고 2003년에 제가
9개 언어 학습 경험에 대해 저서 The Linguist를 썼는데 당시에는
한국어가 포함되지 않았고 LingQ를 시작했습니다.
어쨌든 나는 "그거 알아요? 한국어로 돌아가야 해요!"라고 말했습니다.
그래서 책을 몇 권 더 샀다.
LingQ에는 한국어가 없었어요. 한 권의 책은 매우 좋았고 제가
정말 좋아했던 것은 한국어 개론이라고 하는 것 같습니다.
내 라이브러리를 보여줄 때 알 수 있습니다. 브리티시 컬럼비아 대학교
에서 작성했습니다
. 내레이터의
목소리가 너무 좋았고 모든 종류의 학습 자료
에서 매우 중요합니다
. 지루한 내레이터가 있는 초보자용 책은 있을 수 없습니다. 그것은 단지 나를 끕니다.
그리고 그것은 한국어에 대한 나의 열정의 최고점이었습니다.
또한 책은 패턴으로 가득 차 있었습니다.
언어 학습은 패턴에 관한 것입니다.
그들은 문법적 설명을 가지고 있었고, 연결 동사와 같은 용어를 가지고 있었습니다. 이상한.
그러나 나는 그 모든 설명을 무시했습니다.
나는 그저
패턴을 받아들이고, 패턴을 듣고, 대화를 들었습니다.
일종의 유머러스한 대화였습니다. 내가 어느 정도 익숙했던
학생들의 상황 .
그런 종류의 문화적 전통과 그런 종류의 것에 너무 무겁지 않습니다.
익숙하지 않기 때문에 더 어렵습니다. 그리고 그것은
내가 말했듯이 한국어 학습에 대한 나의 열정의 최고점이었습니다.
그래서 더 많은 책을 샀지만 점점 더 많은 책들이 너무 지루했습니다.
그래서 흥미를 잃기 시작했습니다. 그리고 그 때 대신
러시아어에 관심을 갖게 되었고 LingQ에는 러시아어가 있었습니다. 그리고 얼마 지나지 않아
백미러에 한국어가 등장했고 저는 러시아어에 모든 시간을 할애했습니다.
나는 러시아어에 많은 시간을 보냈습니다.
매우 흥미로운 내용, 정치적 내용, 문학,
오디오북 등 좋은 내용이 너무 많았습니다.
우리는 LingQ에서 그것을 가지고 있었고 그래서 나는 러시아어를 배우기 시작했습니다
. 그리고 체코어와 다른 언어들.
한국어를 다시 시작하려고 정기적으로 시도했지만
2010년에 여러 번 통계를 보여드리면
"좋아요, 3개월 안에 90일 도전을 해야 합니다."라고 말했습니다.
한국어 실력을 향상시키기 위해 무엇을 할 수 있는지 알아보세요.
그리고 나는 내가 향상되었다고 생각합니다.
또는 개선되었지만 물론 가장 오랫동안 사용하지 않았습니다.
마지막에 제가
90일 도전 중 하나를 마치고 튜터와 한국어로 말하는 영상을 보여드리겠습니다.
하지만 여전히 여러 가지 이유로 LingQ에서는 어려웠습니다.
아시다시피 초보자용 콘텐츠가 있었습니다.
미니 스토리가 없었습니다.
중간 내용은 그다지 흥미롭지 않았습니다.
제가 시도한 것은
팟캐스트를 찾는 것이었습니다. 그런 다음 실제로 이 팟캐스트를 필사하도록 누군가에게 돈을 지불했습니다
.
그러나 그들은 매우 어려웠습니다.
하나는 문학 팟캐스트, 다른 하나는 정치 팟캐스트였습니다.
나는 이것들을 통해 내 방식대로 싸웠습니다.
너무 힘들었다.
모르는 단어가 너무 많습니다.
그리고 물론 한국어에는 8가지
의미가 있는 작은 단어가 너무 많고 어떤 의미가 적절한지 몰랐고 현재와 같은
Sentence View가
없었 습니다.
제가 오늘 LingQ에서 한국어 공부하는 방법을 보여드릴께요.
단어를 찾아본 다른 사용자의 사용자 힌트가 더 많으며
단어의 가장 가능성 있는 번역을 빠르게 볼 수 있고 문장을 보면
의미를 더 잘 이해할 수 있습니다.
그 어느 것도 이전에는 사용할 수 없었습니다.
LingQ는 느렸어요. 전에는 느렸어요. 그래서 역풍이 너무 많았습니다
.
너무 어려웠습니다.
그래서 나는 항상 다른 것에 끌렸다.
다시 한 번 한국어에 대한 나의 열정의 최고점을 돌이켜보면
셰익스피어의 율리우스 카이사르
에서 브루투스가 "인간사의 조류에는 조수가 있어 홍수에 휩쓸리면
성공으로 이어질 것"이라고
말한 것이 있습니다 . 그래서 내가 가장 열정적일 때 계속했더라면,
어려움이 덜했더라면, 더 재미있는 콘텐츠가 있었더라면
, LingQ가 더 잘 작동했더라면,
사전이 더 좋았더라면, 이 모든 조건이 충족
되었다면, 매력이 더 크고 저항이 적었다면,
계속해서 더 나은 수준을 달성했을 것이라고 생각합니다.
하지만 한국어에 쏟은 모든 노력이 헛되지는 않습니다.
내 통계에 따르면 약 40~50,000개의 알려진 단어가 있는데
이론적으로 많은 양입니다.
자, 이 모든 언어에서 그것은 우리가 단어를 세는 방법에 달려 있습니다.
한국어에는 문장에서 단어의 기능을 정의하는 데 도움이 되는
다양한 어미가 있습니다 .
따라서 다른 언어와 비교할 수 있는 것이 아닙니다. 하지만 저는 많은
어휘 기반을 가지고 있습니다.
그리고 심지어 이해력까지. 물론 제 중국어도 도움이 됩니다. 그래서 한국에 가더라도
... 자유가 없어요.
나는 가족이 있습니다.
내가하고있는 다른 일이 있습니다.
두 달만 한국에 가서 사람들과 함께 있으면서 항상 한국말만 할
수는 없잖아요 .
하지만 그렇게 된다면 괜찮은 수준으로 끌어올릴 수 있을 것 같다.
그럼에도 불구하고 실망스럽습니다.
1973년에 처음으로 한국 책을 구입했기
때문에 오랜 시간이 지난 것 같습니다.
나는 그 책들을 오랫동안 가지고 있었다.
한국어에 많은 노력을 기울였습니다.
제 책장에 있는 이 책들 중 일부를 열면
밑줄과 눈금 표시 등 온갖 것들이 있는 것을 볼 수 있습니다. 하지만 알다시피
의미 있고 흥미로운 콘텐츠가 있어야 계속 읽을 수 있습니다.
나는 지금 페르시아어를 가지고 있습니다. 일부러 배우려고 하지 않는다는 것입니다.
나는 언어를 즐기는 것보다
의도적으로 언어를 배우려고 너무 많이 노력했습니다
. 언어를 즐길 수 있는 위치에 도달하면
진행이 느려도 즐겁습니다.
나는 한국어가 즐겁지 않은 곳에 도착했습니다. 그것은 일이었습니다.
일할 때는
성공하는 데 필요한 시간을 투자하기가 더 어렵다는 것을 알게 되었습니다.
LingQ에서 한국어를 공부하는 모습을 보여드리면서 마치겠습니다. 그리고 그 후에 제가 말했듯
이 제가 약 90일 동안의 챌린지 중 하나 이후 약 9년 전에 나눈
대화의 비디오를 보실 수 있을 것입니다 .
그래서 한국어를 포기한 것은 아니지만 오랜 시간이 흘렀고
이루고 싶었던 것을 이루지 못했습니다.
듣기 주셔서 감사합니다.
지금은 안녕.
네, 제가 여기서 LingQ로 어떻게 공부하는지 보여드리고 싶어요.
컴퓨터 버전을 사용하겠습니다.
아이패드에서도 할 수 있었습니다.
여기에서 우리 한국어 페이지가 엄청나게 개선된 것을 볼 수 있습니다. 그래서 이제
선택할 수 있는 콘텐츠가 너무 많습니다. 문학,
오디오 북, 복근 운동, 모든 종류의 것들.
시작하려면 이전에는 없었던 미니 스토리가 있습니다.
그 정도면 훨씬 낫습니다.
콘텐츠 측면에서 보고 싶은 수준을 선택할 수도 있습니다.
하지만 예를 들어 보겠습니다.
그래서 여기 제가 찾은 것이 있습니다.
YouTube에서 가져온 것입니다.
이제 이전에는 없었던
YouTube에서 항목을 가져올 수 있습니다
. 여기 제가 우리 도서관에서 찾은 교훈이 있습니다.
YouTube에 가서 직접 찾을 수도 있었지만 어쨌든
이 항목을 클릭할 수 있습니다.
좋아요.
그래서 좀 유치하지만 제가 할 수 있는 일입니다. 좋아, 내가 여기 가면.
그래서 나는 그 문장에 대해서만 오디오를 들을 수 있습니다.
이전에 할 수 있었던 개별 단어를 찾아볼 수 있지만 훨씬 빠릅니다.
그래서 저는 이 모든 다른 의미를 가지고 있습니다. 가장 가능성이
높은 의미가 맨 위에 있습니다. 번역을 표시합니다.
이제 더 많은 문장이 되면 여기에서 볼 수 있습니다.
그래서 이것은 그다지 매력적인 콘텐츠는 아니지만
콘텐츠 가져오기 기능 의 도입으로 LingQ가 얼마나 개선되었는지
보여줍니다 .
이것을 보여드리지만
MP3 파일, 전자책, 레슨을 가져올 수 있으므로 자료를 가져올 수 있습니다.
Audio Transcribe를 가져오면 Whisper AI가 트랜스크립트를 제공하여
레슨을 만들 수 있습니다.
그래서 제가 사용할 수 있는 다양한 유형의 콘텐츠가 있어서 전체
경험이 훨씬 더 유쾌해졌습니다.
여기 조선일보 같은 웹사이트에 가면 한국에 홍수가 났고
홍수에 관한 기사를 고르면
웹 브라우저, 브라우저 확장 프로그램으로 가서 가져올 수 있습니다. 그리고 그것은
LingQ에 들어와서 수업으로 공부할 수 있습니다.
알겠습니다. 파일이 들어오는 동안 몇 초만 기다리겠습니다.
그리고 저는... 이전과 비교하여 변경된 사항 중 하나는
브라우저 확장을 사용하여 클릭 한 번으로 가져올 수 있는 항목의 엄청난 가용성
입니다. YouTube, 신문 기사 등에서.
수업을 엽니다.
수업이 있습니다.
괜찮은.
파란색 텍스트가 많이 있음을 알 수 있습니다.
알 수 없는 단어들입니다.
저는 약 13,000개의 알려진 페르시아어 단어를 가지고 있고 LingQ로 무언가를 가져오면
새로운 단어가 훨씬 적다는 것을
알게 될 것입니다 .
이거 봐요.
여기에는 두 개의 파란색 단어만 있습니다.
페르시아어의 경우,
여기 내 모든 시간 숫자로 이동하면 2018년부터 사용했으며 최대
알려진 단어 추가가 1,000과 같은 것을 볼 수 있습니다.
그리고 그것은 대부분의 경우 최고점입니다.
그것보다 꽤 적습니다.
제가 한국 상황을 보면, 제가
그것에 들인 시간의 양에도 불구하고, 아시다시피 2010년으로 돌아가서
제가 알려진 단어를 4,000개 추가한 날이 있습니다.
지금은 중국어를 알고
한국어로 쟁기질할 수 있다는 사실이 도움이 됩니다. 그리고 점점 더 많은 알려진 단어를 추가하겠지만
여전히 저에게는 어려울 것입니다.
그래서 나는 페르시아어와 달리 한국어에서
일만 하고 일하고 아무데도 가지 않는 느낌이 더 큽니다 .